[Music]
let's just talk about simple things
first Christmas right around the corner
it really snuck up let's not overdo it
shall we it's just a holiday
it can't sneak up on me this year though
it came - yeah nobody has any gifts have
you shopped for anything nobody neither
anything no I'm just leaving it to the
last giving everyone sign headshots
headshot the greatest hey mom I love you
there you go I was a joke first like
have a real gift but just just give them
signed headshots and it just says best
wishes you should do that it'd be fun
yeah you could get really mad you know I
found out today that you had a nickname
as a kid and I don't understand it nitro
why was your nickname as a kid nitro
because I was unstoppably and
uncontrollably hyper oh really
yeah which of course isn't happening now
yeah I came out of it yeah yeah I
couldn't be stopped by medication or
anything did they try medication oh yes
yeah I didn't even make a dent
it's not like you're a rhino that
escaped ensued Wow really so that so you
were just had that much energy yeah I
was just the unbelievably hyper and so
they started calling me nitroglycerin
which got shortened to nitro and yeah it
was really embarrassing is every day and
like go to school and they'd be like
okay today I'm gonna get it together I'm
gonna be cool I'm gonna be calm and then
I'd like show up you know when I was
like 13 I peed my pants and I was in
seventh grade or not peeing my pants by
Pedro and I was sleeping I wet the bed
and I just thought that was like who
wets the bed when they're 13 right and
so I couldn't wait to get to school to
tell everybody what I don't understand
woke up and like look it was like oh my
god I got it I was the alarm gonna go
off what am I gonna get there and then I
like went into the bleachers and was
like everybody I peed my pants or I wet
the bed last night thinking everybody
was gonna think I was like so funny and
cool and like it was just silent
you thought you thought that was gonna
be cool I did that's insane
hi everybody windy and see what I got
for you okay your feathers I bought you
beer and when I wet my bed last night I
hit control my bladder no I never would
have tried that I've never would have
mentioned that ladies line up did your
class to your classmates they must have
thought this is a your different if
nothing else your your ear yeah yeah no
I was weird it was a struggle and every
day I really thought I was gonna like
get it together like I remember on the
first day of school they learned that
the kid sitting behind me name was Ben
and so I just went and how did that go
over with been going there's like more
to them and I don't want to do it here
do you know when you say I don't want to
talk about it it means that's all we're
talking about that's so crazy
that's right but you were just creative
and fun you were Nitro man